So today I want to have a slightly different
conversation, will lead to impeachment.
I think it's an important one and it's actually
one that may, um, uh, at least opened the
door to achieving something politically rather
than focusing on the removal of president
Trump.
And what I mean by this is that when the topic
of impeachment or Donald Trump comes up, 99%
of the time, it's someone talking about obstruction
of justice or witness tampering basically
related directly or indirectly to the Mueller
probe.
And I believe that there is a completely reasonable
case to be made for impeachment over obstruction.
But as I've said before, it's just not going
to happen in the sense that Republicans aren't
going to go for it.
It will be framed by Republicans as a partisan
act by Democrats to try to impeach Donald
Donald Trump over obstruction.
It may still achieve a 20, 20 strategic goal,
but in terms of achieving an immediate political,
uh, uh, sort of change, it's just not going
to happen.
So my suggestion today is, let's put that
aside for a second.
Okay.
Let's completely forget about obstruction
and impeachment because you don't actually
need obstruction to justify impeachment proceedings
against Donald Trump.
This is barely being talked about, but there
are a couple of articles about the description.
Yes, this youtube clip, but looking only at
Donald Trump's actions in Yemen and arguably
looking at Donald Trump's violations of the
emoluments clause, you would have 110% justification
for the impeachment of the president of the
United States.
Let's go through each of them one by one and
remember, none of this has anything to do
with obstruction.
None of this has anything to do with the Mueller
report.
None of this has anything to do with collusion
or conspiracy to collude with Russia.
Donald Trump's support for the Saudi led attacked
on Yemen are arguably an impeachable offense.
Okay.
The Senate has already passed a war powers
resolution, which is meant to stop American
military support for the Saudi attack on Yemen
that has been going on.
Donald Trump has said he would veto that Trump
will prevent us from saying, hold on a second.
We're not going to fund this immoral and unconscionable
war on Yemen by Saudi Arabia anymore.
Trump says he would prevent this from no longer
funding that.
Now there are other things that Congress could
do when it comes to Yemen.
Congress could override Trump's veto of that
war powers resolution.
Not Clear that they actually have the numbers
to do that in the political will to do that.
Um, but there is a, the possibility of Congress
cutting the money that is used for supporting
these attacks.
Trump can authorize it.
A Trump can say he wants to do it.
He can, he can veto the war powers resolution.
But Congress still could stop the flow of
the money itself as his congresses, a constitutionally
established duty.
But there is a very strong case for impeachment
of Donald Trump over this.
Now you might say, wait a second, David, you
just said Senate Republicans aren't going
to vote to remove Trump if he's impeached
by the house.
And that's true.
But remember to start impeachment proceedings,
you don't need two thirds of the Senate.
You only need 50% plus one in the house, which
Democrats have.
If Democrats impeach over obstruction, that
will trigger one type of reaction from Trump
and he will buckle down.
It'll be super partisan.
Republicans are gonna have Trump's back.
If Democrats instead start impeachment or
even threatened to start impeachment over
what is arguably military and financial support
of unconstitutional participation in the Saudi
war on Yemen, it's going to be less partisan.
I'm not saying it won't be partisan, but there
are already some Republicans who want to end
American support of the Saudi war on Yemen.
And it might even pull some of the prominent
house Democrats that oppose impeachment like
Nancy Pelosi over to our side.
And the thing is, it's not about removing
Trump.
It might actually get Trump to stop supporting
Saudis war on Yemen.
It would actually do something, at least potentially
the possibility of possible impeachment over
Yemen might even get Trump to stop support
by the US military, uh, of Saudi Arabia in
Yemen without needing impeachment in and of
itself to even get going in earnest.
And then lastly, totally separately, uh, there's
a case to be made that Donald Trump has violated
the emoluments clause in multiple ways, receiving
things of value from foreign nations, including
endless hotel revenue from foreign leaders
and diplomats who say, we're staying at Trump's
hotel in Washington DC specifically to curry
favor with them to ingratiate ourselves with
Donald Trump to maybe achieve some kind of
favorable position from Donald Trump directly
or from his administration or his Justice
Department or Commerce Department or whoever
else it is.
You could make the argument on a monument
for impeachment, but again, this would be
specifically because of Yemen, less political
than obstruction, 100% legally warranted.
Uh, and I think it is a serious debate that
within the democratic establishment has to
happen.
I believe that the threat of impeachment immediately
via impeachment hearings in the house over
Yemen could actually get Donald Trump to change
his policy on that issue.
And it would directly help the people, people
of Yemen obstruction impeachment.
You're going to get the immediate buckle down
the witch hunt stuff.
You're going to get a very, very different
reaction over Yemen dumped.
If Donald Trump, uh, sees that simply stopping
our support of the Saudi war there might make
that threat of impeachment go away, it's actually
possible possible that he would go forward
and
do that.